peu
[Musique]
on
à
[Musique]
bonsoir le mois dernier vous vous en
souvenez peut-être je vous parlais de la
comtesse de castiglione
je vous ai également parlé assez souvent
du courrier que vous avez la bonté de
m'adresser
parce que ce courrier pour moi sorte de
prolongement de cette émission qui est
fatalement unilatérale et une fois de
plus ce courrier vous m'adressez
régulièrement après chaque émission
m'apporter une joie je vous racontais je
racontais le mois dernier qu ayant écrit
la vie de la comtesse de castiglione il
ya de ça plus de vingt ans je m'étais
rendu sur sa tombe que j'avais trouvée
couverte de mousse les caractères étant
presque illisible et que j'avais été
porté quelques fleurs à la comtesse de
castiglione or deux jours après
l'émission
je reçois une lettre linda merci madame
qui me dit monsieur je tiens à vous
informer que depuis que vous êtes allé
sur l'atome de la comtesse de
castiglione quelqu'un d'autre y va parce
que la tante de ma famille n'est pas
loin et que chaque fois que je vais sur
la temps de ma famille eh bien je vois
qu'on entretient parfaitement bien la
tempe de la castiglione mêmes
il y a des fleurs en permanence alors je
tenais ce que vous le sachiez
ah j'étais intrigué vous l'êtes je pense
avec moi comment par quel miracle
cette femme qui n'a plus de famille
cette femme presque oublié par quel
miracle cette femme at-elle la chance
d'avoir ça tombe entretenu et fleurie
par l'énigme était posé deux jours
encore et une nouvelle lettre
voilà l'énigme était déjà résolue c'est
un monsieur cette fois
merci monsieur qui m'écrivait pour me
dire j'ai un ami
qui est inculte pour la comtesse de
castiglione et cet ami entretien satan
il lui porte régulièrement les fleurs et
comme il n'a que 40 ans eh bien on peut
bien penser que pendant de nombreuses
années encore la tombe de la castiglione
sera entretenue et bien voilà bien sûr
ça n'est pas un événement qui
révolutionne histoire mais je trouve ça
très charmant mais je voulais vous en
faire part alors ce soir nous allons
parler d'eux du masque de fer
pourquoi le masque de fer et bien c'est
une fois encore le courrier qui on est
responsable parce que depuis quelques
mois vous avez été nombreux à m'écrire à
me dire qu'en frais vous le masque de
fer alors pourquoi pas faire le masque
de fer c'est la dernière émission avant
les vacances
alors partons partons ensemble vers des
pays de vacances et parlons de cette
énigme qui est probablement avec celle
de louis 17
celle qui a fait couler le plus d'encre
alors justement quand vous êtes en
vacances sur la côte d'azur
si vous êtes à cannes eh bien il vous
est sûrement arrivé de prendre un un de
ses bateaux qui quitte le port de cannes
vers les îles de lerins et avant d'aller
à saint-honorat ce bateau s'arrête à
l'île de ste marguerite alors vous avez
sûrement fait comme moi dans ce cas
sinon faites le vous y engage si vous
êtes dans le midi cet été
quand vous arrivez sur l'île vous montez
un sentier en forme de raidillons vous
avez devant devant une grande porte à
porte dans sainte pour pénétrer dans la
cour
et puis dans un bâtiment là vous entrez
dans un couloir
plusieurs portes
à franchir et enfin une cellule une
cellule qui est la cellule de l'homme au
masque de fer elle est assez grande elle
à 6 mètres sur 5 environ des quatre
mètres cinquante de plafond
la fenêtre ouvre sur la mer on aperçoit
au loin le le rivage de cannes et puis
il y à cette fenêtre une triple grille
mais bien évident qu'il est impossible
de franchir cette grille de s'évader
d'une manière ou d'une autre
d'un côté une cheminée de l'autre les
lieux et lieux d'aisance voilà la
cellule du masque de fer et vienne la
première fois que j'y suis allé il ya
tout de même pas mal d'années il y avait
à ce moment là un vieux guide charmant
d'ailleurs avec une moustache qui avait
l'accent bien sûr de l'endroit et qui
disait à la troupe de gens qui le
suivait en entrant dans cette pièce et
bien le voici maintenant dans la chambre
du masque de fait autrement dit le frère
jumeau de louis xiv
alors là il y avait dans le public une
sorte de frémissement parce que mon dieu
c'était bien ce que pensaient les gens
parce que c'est ça l'histoire du masque
de fer c'est ça la rumeur populaire la
légende tout ce qu'on voudra mais enfin
dans le public français la conviction
que le masque de fer était le frère
jumeau de louis xiv et naturellement
ancrée et cette conviction est ancrée
depuis le vicomte de bragelonne du chef
alexandre dumas alors on a lu le vicomte
de bragelonne
on se souvient de la machination
mise au point par aramis pour substituer
roi louis xiv son frère jumeau il fait
ça en usant de la naïveté de porthos et
vous savez comment toutes échoué à cause
de fouquet enfin inutile de vous
raconter ça vous l'avez alors bien
entendu quand on disait aux gens
dans la chambre de l'île sainte
marguerite
voici la cellule du frère jumeau louis
xiv souvent le croyait alors justement
nous sommes ici pour nous poser des
questions et pour peut-être et j'espère
que vous m'en excuserez que vous me
pardonnerez peut-être tuer les gens
alors cette histoire finalement comment
la connais ton
comment est elle née quand comment bah
c'est tout simple
s'il n'avait pas existé un jour à
monsieur appeler voltaire je serais pas
en train de vous parler du masculin
c'est en 1951 que voltaire publie son
grand ouvrage le siècle de louis xiv et
qu'est ce qu'on lit dans ce livre avec
beaucoup d'autres choses bien sûr qu'est
ce qu'on y lit au chapitre 25 ceci
quelques temps après la mort du cardinal
mazarin qui se produisit en france un
événement bien étrange
il arriva à l'île de ste marguerite un
prisonnier de belles allures de belle
taille et ce prisonnier avaient le
visage masqué son masque la mentonnière
de son masque porté des ressorts d'acier
afin probablement de lui permettre de
manger
on ne sait pas qui est cette 1 on sait
que les officiers du fort lui parlait
avec les plus grands égards on sait
qu'il avait un goût très prononcé pour
le linge fin et qu'il jouait de la
guitare
on remarquera dit voltaire qu'il n'a
disparu à cette époque aucun personnage
considérable en europe
mais voilà la sphère été lancée la
sphère été lancée parce que tout y était
imaginez le lecteur du xviiie siècle qui
lis ce chapitre 25e il est formellement
t'exciter il tient plus en place mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
et puis enfin se massent ses ressorts
dassier alors le public va retenir
l'expression ressort d'acier et appliqué
le mot acier à tous le masque qu'il y
aura un masque dacia masque de fer faut
rendre justice à volterra mais parler de
masque de fer m'enfin à cause de ses
ressorts d'acier il a donné son élan à
la légère or ça fait tant de bruit cette
publication de voltaire que l'année
d'après profitant d'une réimpression
il ajoute quelques les
elle raconte ceci le prisonnier masqué
inconnue de cette marguerite avait un
jour écrit sur une de ses assiettes
d'argent avec probablement un couteau et
il avait lancé l'assiette par la fenêtre
un pêcheur la trouva et en toute bonne
foi leur apporta au gouverneur monsieur
deçà de celui ci regarde al pêcheurs
celui ci regarde à l'assiette lui ce qui
était écrit sur l'assiette et demanda
aux pêcheurs ce qu'il en pensait le
pêcheur répondit mais monseigneur je ne
sais pas lire
là tu montres et à quelqu'un à personne
eh bien tu es bien heureux de ne pas
savoir lire et il a laissé partir
dans ce même supplément
il était question non pas dans le même
supplément parce que un an encore se
passe nouvelle réimpression ça marche
très bien le siècle de louis xiv
nouvelle réimpression une nouvelle
addition par voltaire il fait les choses
admirables
on comprend très bien que mich les ai
dit de lui que c'est un gigantesque de
journalistes
alors là il donne ses sources parce que
sans doute que des gens avaient discuté
en vue du mans fox qui lançait cette
histoire d'une assiette
alors il répond je tiens l'histoire de
monsieur rioux ce fonctionnaire du roi
dans la région de cannes qui l'a raconté
dans lé telles conditions il donne ses
sources et il ajoute que le dernier
ministre à avoir connu le secret de
l'homme au masque et monsieur chat
milliard et que celui-ci pressés à son
lit de mort par son gendre le second
maréchal de la feuillade a répondu
d'abord que c'était le secret de l'état
qui pouvait pas le nez puis enfin
finalement il dit c'est un homme qui
connaissait les secrets de monsieur
fouquet voilà évidemment voltaire
commenté dimanche ça c'est très bizarre
comme réponse les secrets de monsieur
fouquet alors c'était un subalterne
alors pourquoi des précautions aussi
inouïe pour un subalterne
il termine sur un point d'interrogation
ce qui est excellent puis les années
passent en dix et cent soixante dix et
oui les années ont passé beaucoup
d'années
voltaire revient encore sur la sphère et
cette fois il va plus loin il dit au
fond il n'y a qu'une explication à ce
masque c'est une affaire de ressemblance
c'est que l'homme dont on recouvre le
visage ressemble à quelqu'un de si connu
qu'il est nécessaire de lui cacher le
visage justement pour qu'on ne le
reconnaissent pas ces salles
explications mais ne va pas plus loin et
un an encore se passe nous sommes en
il y a vingt ans qu'il a commencé à
parler l'oeuvre de l'homme au masque et
bien voilà qu'un livre de voltaire par
est de nouveau et cette fois c'est une
addition de l'éditeur sas est
extraordinairement futé
vous pensez bien que l'addition de
l'éditeur a été rédigée de la blanche
man monsieur de voltaire et cette
addition de l'éditeur dit ceci je me
suis demandé moi éditeur ce que voulait
dire monsieur de volts et je crois avoir
compris il s'agit du frère il s'agit
certainement d'un frère aîné de louis
xiv
c'est la seule explication la
ressemblance est certainement qu'il
devait ressembler beaucoup à son frais
que probablement l'enfant a été élevé
secrètement que le roi n'a dû le savoir
que quand il est arrivé aux affaires
après la mort du cardinal mazarin et que
là il se trouvant devant après s'est
trouvé devant un problème il n'était pas
possible pour l'état qu'un frère aîné
même adultérin mais nés dans le mariage
donc légitime vis-à-vis de la loi et de
l'église
il n'était pas possible qu'un frère de
ce genre soit en liberté puisse
éventuellement réunir un parti louis xiv
penser aux guerres de la fronde
pensez aussi aux guerres aux guerres
civiles du temps de louis xiii et à
l'action si défavorable de gaston
d'orléans alors louis xiv répugnant ni
l'éditeur sur l'éditeur qui par la
commette un acte définitif c'est à dire
à pignan assassiné en vrai a décidé de
mettre dans une prison avec un masque
voilà l'histoire l'histoire était bouclé
et elle été lancée pour de nombreuses
années
parce qu'évidemment beaucoup de gens
s'en dit évidemment c'est plausible
c'est probable et puis d'autres ont dû
menons ce pas sérieux enfin une
naissance royal la reine a toujours vécu
entourés d'une cour elle n'a pas pu
dissimuler une grossesse alors d'autres
gens se sont mis sur cette même thème a
cherché une autre solution et les
solutions il y en a des dizaines
alors il ya par exemple la solution de
monsieur de beaufort
certains ont affirmé assez vite que
monsieur beaufort le petit-fils d'henri
iv et de gabrielle d'estrées qu'on
croyait avoir été tué à candy et bien
que monsieur de beaufort avait survécu
et qu'on l'avait incarcéré justement
avec ce masque mais pourquoi monsieur le
beaufort pourquoi ce masque que c'est
une thèse qui est bien difficile à
admettre
et puis d'autres ont parlé du duc de
mots ce qui était un bâtard de charles 2
alors pourquoi le duc de monde moss
d'ailleurs on l'a retrouvé les traces de
son passage sur cette terre bien après
la date de l'incarcération de l'homme au
masque par conséquent ça n'est pas lui
on a parlé du comte de vermandois fils
de louis xiv et de mademoiselle de la
vallière et là aussi on a bien la trace
de la mort du comte de vermandois il est
très possible il est difficile
impossible même d'admettre cette thèse
mais elle a été soutenue
on a même dit qu'il s'agissait d' avait
dit qu avait dit qu'à patriarche
arménien mon dieu pourquoi aller
chercher un patriarche arménien et puis
je crois que la palme doit être donné un
avocat maître bush qui a démontré très
sérieusement dans une thèse que l'homme
au masque de fer était une femme alors
là évidemment on reste sans voix
il ya encore une thèse qui est très
étonnante c'est celle d'anatole l'ocam
qui voulaient voir dans le masque de fer
molière vous êtes étonné parce que vous
vous dites quoi on le connaît la connaît
l'histoire de molière le malade
imaginaire il a été pris d'un saignement
ide en tunisie d'une émeute tizi et il
est mort quelques temps plus tard dans
chez lui où l'avait transporté mais non
monsieur look un dîner dit que tout
autre chose
molière avait des ennemis qui étaient
les jésuites et les jésuites ont obtenu
finalement sa tête de louis xiv on l'a
arrêté sur l'ordre de louis xiv on
l'achetait dans un cul de basse fosse
ont bien mis un masque parce
qu'évidemment mollir était très connu là
aussi disons que c'est une thèse que
nous n'allons pas retenir y en a une
autre qui date du premier empire
comme quoi le masque l'homme masqué
cette marguerite aurait fait un mariage
secret avec une jeune fille et des
enfants seraient nés et notamment on
aurait porté en corse un fils et on
aurait dit à la famille à qui on le
confier nous voulant voyons de bonnes
par ceux qui en dialecte corse seraient
devenus des bois la part des ce qui fait
que l'enfant aurait pris ce nom des bois
l'appart et quelques générations plus
tard
un certain napoléon ce rennais dans
l'île de corse lequel descendent et par
conséquent en ligne directe des rois de
france et une thèse admirable napoléon a
raconté à saint-helens ceux qui
l'avaient accompagné
pour s'en amuser naturellement je crois
que il faut abandonner cette légende
constaté seulement que la sphère du
masque de fer fait rêver beaucoup plus
que d'autres pris visuel suscite toutes
ses thèses
je lisais dans un journal cette semaine
qu'ils en avaient 48 je n'en ai pas
dénombrer 48 mais c'est possible quand
je crois qu'il faut être maintenant
plutôt revenir à l'histoire et nous
servir de quelque chose de concret dont
nous disposons qui est la correspondance
entre le ministre louvois et le gardien
de l'homme au masque qui monsieur de sam
cette correspondance comporte des
centaines de lettres certaines très
précises qui nous informe d'une manière
très complète d'autres malheureusement
très imprécise et c'est tout le problème
alors l'histoire commence en 16 160
c'est pourquoi en 765 parce que cette
année là monsieur de sama prend le
gouvernement du donjon de la citadelle
de pignol qu'est ce que c'est que
pignerol pignerol est une citadelle
française en italie sur le revers
italien des alpes
c'est louis xiii qui a acquis la place
de pignerolle richelieu la fortifier il
ya donc un donjon il y à une citadelle
la citadelle est commandée par le
marquis de piennes et le donjon depuis
16 165 et commandé par monsieur de saint
marc bessin mars qui s c'est un homme de
petite naissance il s'appelait bénigne
d'auvergne d'auvergne en un mot il a été
enfant de troupe à 12 ans et puis
ensuite il a été mus que terre il a eu
un coup de génie le jour de
l'arrestation de fouquet par d'artagnan
du surintendant fouquet par d'artagnan
il a arrêté lui
pélisson le collaborateur et surtout
l'ami de fouquet et ayant bien accompli
cette mission il a été bien vue par le
roi et quand on la cherchait un gardien
à pignerol pour fouquet qui était jeté
par le roi en détention perpétuelle
eh bien on l'a désigné sama ne sortent
que
mousquetaires est devenu commandant
d'une place du roi et en même temps
geôliers supérieur dans la
correspondance de louvois avec sa mort
nous vous assistons à la dure captivité
du malheureux de l'infortuné fouquet
victime d'une vengeance pas très belle
le roi louis xiv et puis en 769 nous
découvrons du nouveau vous qui restez
seul il parle à personne une voix
personnes il peut même écrire à sa
famille ne reçoit pas de l'être rien
c'est la solitude puis s'amarrer la
puissance et 169 sasha samar reçoit une
lettre de louvois et cette lettre est
très curieuse elle annonce l'arrivée
d'un prisonnier et 10e prisonniers il
faut que vous preniez à son égard des
précautions telles que vous n'en avez
jamais prise le prisonnier a été arrêté
à dunkerque par monsieur nouveau roi
elle va vous être amené à pignerol alors
il faut comme vous aménager une cellule
pour lui spéciale de telle façon que la
fenêtre de cette cellule donne en un
lieu où personne ne pourra passer ou
personne ne pourra entendre ce que dira
ce prisonnier où le prisonnier ne pourra
pas entendre ce qu'on dit du dehors
quant à la porte il faut qu'il y en ait
trois 3 portes afin qu'un aucun moment
on des gens qui passerait par là
l'intérieur de la citadelle à
l'intérieur du donjon puisse entendre ce
que dirait le briser et ce prisonnier
c'est vous monsieur sam qui chaque jour
irait lui porter sont nécessaires c'est
à dire ces aliments sa nourriture et je
vous interdis vous monsieur de
saint-marc d'écouté jamais ce prisonnier
si jamais il voulais vous parler si
jamais vous voulez vous dire ce qu'il a
fait avant de venir à pignerol ce à quoi
il a été employé
alors il faudrait le faire mourir ainsi
même saint-marc ne doit pas savoir ce
qu'a fait l'homme qui va arriver
et décidément natacha cet homme une
importance énorme parce que
le roi louis xiv va lui même écrit à
monsieur depienne le gouverneur la
citadelle et vais demander à monsieur
depienne de mettre au service de
monsieur de saint-marc toute sa force
armée au cas ils en auraient besoin
lorsque le prisonnier arriverait comment
une force armée pour un prisonnier
unique de de plus sa marque dans son
donjon c'est marcel pagnol qui l'a
constaté dans son donjon saint-marc
disposer de soixante six hommes et de
cinq ou six vallées il avait de quoi
largement garder ce prisonnier et le roi
louis xiv va écrire à saint-marc
également lui dire monsieur de
saint-marc je compte sur vous vous ne
devez vous le devez avoir aucune espèce
de communication avec le prisonnier qui
va vous être amenées alors pendant des
jours ont fait d'énormes travaux dans le
donjon ça coûte d'ailleurs un prix fou
et on amène le prisonnier un détail
louvois a écrit dans une de ses lettres
il s'agit d'un valet alors première
contradiction premier problème pourquoi
elle valait et pourquoi des précautions
aussi inouïe points valaient que nous
aurons d'autres questions à nous poser
alors les années passent cinq ans cinq
années où l'homme étant fermée
complètement le parlant à personne ne
voyant personne sauf saint marc une fois
par jour 2 pouvant même avoir aucune
conversation avec sam il ne lit pas il
n'a rien d'autre à ce régime il y aura
d'autres prisonniers dans le donjon nous
en parlerons deviendront fou presque
tous les prisonniers enfermés dans cette
solitude abominable deviennent fous pas
lui alors que sait-on de lui seulement
son nom parce que l'on voit la donner il
s'appelle eustache dauger un valet nommé
eustache dauger qui est la forme est
enfermé pendant cinq années
puis brute de cinq années se produit
quelque chose parce qu'il ya eu d'abord
un autre prisonnier qui est arrivé au
donjon c'est celle aux 1 laws un petit
gentilhomme gascon tout à fait est un an
lauzun qui s'est hissé dans la vie avec
une maestria digne d'admiration lauzun
qui a failli épouser la grande
mademoiselle c'est à dire la quizaine la
cousine germaine de louis xiv et
finalement le mariage n'a pas eu lieu
l'oim a fait décoller ray et louis xiv
la revoyait pignerol tout simple alors
l'arrivée de l'oim change quelque chose
parce que lowe's a besoin d'un valet
c'est un homme de qualité dont il a
besoin d'avaler et samara une idée
pourquoi ne pas lui donner dauger le
pauvre qu'il a depuis cinq ans puisque
on lui a dit que c'était avaler alors
puisqu'il est valais où le tenant lieu à
losail louvois répond jamais la vie
surtout ne faites pas ce bon quelques
temps se passe encore et puis fouquet
qui a deux vallées l'un des vallées
moeurs et samaa revient la charge
pourquoi ne pas lui donner comme second
vallée d'auge et cette fois louvois
accepte
ouais de sorte qu'on va tirer dauger son
cul de basse fosse et on imagine ce
qu'elle a dû être pour cet homme là qui
sortait d'une agonie pour entrer dans
une vie presque normale vous qu'il y
avait une belle chambre un bel
appartement il y avait une fenêtre
envoyer la montagne il parlait avec un
homme courtois d' distinguer cultivé qui
étaient coupées il avait un camarade qui
était la rivière l'autre vallée et ça a
duré cinq ans pendant lesquels je pense
que relativement à sa première
incarcération
doré a dû être à peu près heureux et
puis la prison de de fouquet s'est
adouci peu à peu il ya eu des ordres qui
ont été donnés depuis paris et ses
ordres c'était que peu à peu fou qu'est
pourrait recevoir des visites la visite
de lauzun par exemple et plus ils
pourraient aller voir lauzun et puis ils
pourraient même se promener sur les
remparts et puis il pourrait recevoir
des visites de personnes de la ville
alors là nous ne comprenons plus parce
que nous nous disons enfin qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
ce dauger qui ne devait parler à
personne
saint-marc devait lui passer son épée à
travers le ventre si jamais lui ouvrait
la bouche qui m'attend le laisse aller
venir on le laisse là dans cette prison
et puis va rencontrer lauzun on peut
penser et ça a été le raisonnement
certainement louvois dont le donnant à
fouquet qui sortirait jamais mais ce
n'était pas grave parce que si dauger
raconter quelque chose à fouquet bien
fouquet l'emporterait avec lui c'est
pour ça qu'on ne voulait pas le donner à
lauzun qui lui on savait bien sortir et
un jour mais alors salle ce raisonnement
ne tenait plus du tout puisque lauzun
voyait fouquet attention c'est que l'on
voit tout prévu et les ordres sont
précis dauger peut bien être avec
fouquet mais dès que lauzun entre on
doit retirer dauger leur met dans sa
prison s'il ya des visites de personnes
de l'extérieur d'ogero pts rentrer dans
sa prison il y rentre d'ailleurs tous
les soirs pour y dormir
alors là on commence tout de même à
comprendre
et puis en 80 ans et 180 événement
fouquet moeurs rentrer dans la chambre
pour la nettoyer et on découvre un trou
un trou entre eux la cellule de l'osa et
celle de fouquet c'est probablement le
remuant lauzun qu'il a fait ce trou
grâce à ça il a pu communiquer en secret
avec fougue et en dehors de la présence
de samaa et affolement de 5 alors lauzun
qui va sortir lui a pu par le trou voir
dauger il a pu entendre peut être un
récit de dauger et peut-être même que
dont j'ai raconté son histoire à fouquet
qui l'a raconté à l'osa puisqu'il y
avait plus la surveillance de sa main ce
que savait dauger était pour nous voit
si important que du vivant de fouquet
louvre avait écrit la plus extravagante
des lettres qu'un prisonnier avait
jamais reçus fouquet est en prison il
reçoit cette lettre du ministre monsieur
fouquet le roi un service à vous
demander
il veut savoir si le nommer dauger n'a
pas raconté ce qu'il avait fait avant de
venir à pignerol alors vous seriez bien
de m'écrire là dessus le roi en sera
très satisfaits et inutile de faire
passer la led permet ceux de saint marc
a dressé la moins directement il ya donc
toujours secrets de nogent alors
peut-être que lauzun va connaître ce
secret et louvoie une idée cette idée
est à la fois machiavélique est terrible
louvois créée à saint mard vous allez
dire à monsieur lowe's que dauger et la
rivière l'autre vallée vanne est
d'ailleurs volontaires qui étaient venus
volontairement par fidélité à fouquet
dans cette prison vous allez dire à
monsieur lozach dauger est là
vié ont été libérés mais naturellement
vous ne les libérez pas vous allez les
mettre dans un cachot de la tour dans
bâle tour la plus terrible la plus
redoutable et vous arrangé pour que
personne dans le donjon dans la
citadelle dans la ville ne sache que ces
deux hommes sont encore là c'est fini
debout qu'il savait des hommes ils ont
disparu mais vous dites à lauzun qui
sont libérés pour quoi faire bien sûr
parce que si on dit à lauzun qu'ils sont
libérés s'ils osent un a entendu un
secret l'audience doit se dire bon alors
c'est une blague
c'est énorme chose qu'on m'a raconté de
dauger c'est parce c'est pas sérieux
parce qu'en face il avait fait 100
l'oreille aux médias non l'homme jamais
libéré et d'un seul coup dauger et est
démonétisé vis-à-vis de lauzun c'est
bien ce qui s'est passé parce que le vin
est sorti puis n'a plus jamais pensé à
dauger qui était l'hymne et dauger la
rivière eux sont dans leur cul de basse
fosse où ils vont encore rester des
années
imaginez ces gens qui ont connu une
seule liberté là dans cet appartement
qui ont pu même se promener sur les
remparts avec monsieur fouquet penser à
la rivière qui est venu je le répète
volontairement parce qu'on a un secret à
garder bien ce malheureux la rivière est
maintenant au fond un souterrain dans un
moment affreux dans une vie affreuse
jusqu'au jour où s'amarrent va être
nommé gouverneur de la place d'exil la
plaque exil existe toujours et à exil
dauger va partir en exil
samar va remplacer le duc de
lesdiguières pour gouverner cette place
cette place qui est à exactement à 50 km
de pignerolle qui est entre turin et
briançon et cette place il va la
gouverner il va y emmener qui est bien
ces deux prisonniers la rivière
et dauger et pourtant il y avait
d'autres prisonniers qui étaient arrivés
à pignerol
et ces prisonniers vont rester lapinière
il faut en dire un mot
ces prisonniers se sont d'abord à moins
de jacobins qui avait fait de l'alchimie
qui avait plus ou moins était aimé des
dames qui tournait autour de lui parce
que elle rêvait qu'il leur dévoile le
secret de la pierre philosophale il ya
vu une mademoiselle d'armagnac
mademoiselle de würth imbert on avait
fini par l'arrêter on premise visconti
parle de ce monde jacobins c'est très
probablement celui là il y avait eu
aussi un petit espion a nommé dubreuil
qui avait trafiqué qui avait vendu les
plans des armées allemandes aux armées
françaises et les plans des armées
françaises aux armées allemandes ça
n'avait pas plu à louis xiv on l'avait
arrêté on l'avait jetée à pignerol
il y avait quelqu'un de plus important
qui était le comte mattioli le comte
mathieu lit un italien ministre du duc
de mantoue qui avait été chargé de
négocier la vente de la place forte de
cazals qui appartenait au duc de mantoue
au roi louis xiv alors on avait envoyé
mattioli à paris il avait négocié la
cession de la place c'était très bien
louis xiv avait donc une place de plus
en italie on l'avait donné un très beau
cadeau à mattioli et quand il était
rentré l'italie s'était empressé de
trahir à la fois louis xiv et le duc de
mantoue en vendant la mèche à tous les
principes à liens de manière à trouve
percevoir de nouveau pour moi
vous savez ce sont des choses que louis
xiv ne tolérait pas on a tendu un piège
à mattioli la bd strates de notre
ambassadeur à venise est allé lui
donnait rendez-vous les montées sans
méfiance dans la voiture de l'abbé
d'estrade laquelle voiture s'est
rapproché de la frontière française et à
ce moment-là partie de cavaliers a
franchi la frontière française arrêtée
matière lit et on l'a jeté dans la tour
dans le donjon de pignerol mais ces
prisonniers qui évidemment leur rôle à
jouer bien ces prisonniers samar les a
laissés à pignol et c'est important de
les énumérer
parce que mathématiquement il faut que
l'homme au masque
notre homme masque soit l'un des
prisonniers de saint marc au moment où
il quitte pignerol en 780 alors qu'ils
sont les prisonniers moment ultime
pignerol je le répète c'est dauger c'est
la rivière c'est le moine jacobins c'est
du breuil et c'est mattioli qu'on
retourne le problème dans tous les sens
on en arrive à cette nécessité
il y en a pas d'autre c'est parmi ces
cinq là qu'il faut chercher l'homme au
masque alors d'abord il faut bien se
dire que si on trouve important si
louvois trouve important que saint marc
emmène dauger la rivière exil et pas les
autres
c'est peut-être que l'un des deux a plus
d'importance que les autres alors c'est
pas le prouve la rivière le pauvre
vallée qui suit le sort de dauger bon
gré mal gré c'est dauger aura exil de
nouveau c'est la prison celle ci lance
et même en 783 on retire alors
confesseur aux prisonniers toujours de
peur qu'ils parlent toujours se traite
dauger et puis la rivière meurt à exil
et puis saint marc est nommé gouverneur
des îles sainte marguerite
il faut donc qu'il emmène son prisonnier
e stage dauger il l'emmène à
sainte-marguerite comment va-t-il faire
nouvel ordre de louvois il le faut à
aucun prix que personne ne voit son
visage que personne ne l'entendent
parler qu'il n'ait entendent personne
alors une idée
une idée prendre une chaise à porteurs
la recouvrir d'une toile cirée
et c'est ainsi que en plusieurs jours
on est allé de exil jusqu'à cannes il ya
quelques années en ami le photographe
jean la tête s'était amusé à
reconstituer une chaise à porteurs
recouverte de toile cirée qu'il avait
posé devant les rochers du cal devant
les est marguerite qui se profile à
l'horizon
et en effet on peut penser que c'est une
chaise de ce genre qui a été utilisée
pour celui qui n'est pas encore l'homme
au masque mais l'homme qu'on ne doit pas
voir l'homme donc il ne faut pas voir le
visage un accident c'est que le
malheureux a failli étouffer sous sa
toile sirem et qu'il était à demi moore
en arrivant alors on l'a conduit sur un
bateau jusque dans les indes marguerite
et on l'a écroué dans la fameuse on a
franchi la porte dans sainte et puis on
est arrivé dans la dans la citadelle et
on l'a écroué dans la fameuse chambre
que nous connaissons des gens nous
sommes allés tout à l'heure et à partir
de ce moment là eh bien on peut suivre à
peu près la vie de cet homme à sainte
marguerite
ce qu'on sait c'est que hans hess 194,2
prisonniers rejoignent saint mars et
mathieu liebert oui le vieux mattioli et
puis dubreuil qu'il rejoigne à sainte
marguerite
ils sont venus à pied semble-t-il avec
des gardes
louvois a écrit avec mépris à saint-marc
il est inutile que veulent aller au
devant d'eux
quelle différence avec les le voyage de
dauger dans sa chaise à toile cirée
quant au moins des jacobins il est mort
à pignerol ça fait déjà deux morts
lemoine et la rivière qui sont éliminés
en ce qui concerne le problème de
l'homme au masque de fer et crotta
mattioli à peine arrivé à sainte
marguerite et bien il semble qu'il soit
mort pour une quantité de raisons c'est
que il avait avalé qu'on apprend que le
prisonnier qui est mort à avaler
ensuite tu es bien l'histoire de son
enlèvement n'était plus secrètes depuis
longtemps par conséquent ne le prenais
plus au sérieux leur île son nom figurer
ouvertement dans la correspondance alors
qu'on cache et les autres non et puis
tout à coup on trouve plus du tout son
nom dans la correspondance on avait plus
forte rend les raisons de penser qu'il
est mort là à sainte marguerite
donc il n'y a plus de survivant parmi
les cinq que du breuil et que dauger
dubreuil personne ne s'est jamais occupé
de lui quand l'on voit écrit à son
propos très rarement d'ailleurs il
appelle un fripon du bruit n'a aucune
importance on connaît bien son histoire
c'est mal c'est pas le procès pas le
masque alors est ce qu il reste dauger
est justement à partir de sainte
marguerite dauger va recevoir un masque
et nous savons par des témoignages
sérieux il ya le témoignage de la mode
guérin c'est encore marcel pagnol qui a
beaucoup travaillé très bien travaillé
sur le masque le fait qui a souligné
l'importance du témoignage de la mode
guérin il lui a donné sa valeur en
soulignant que la mode guérin était bien
un véritable hit et moi la mode guerra
nous parle de l'homme qui était en effet
masqué parle de sale du linge fin qui il
est mais des égards qu'on avait pour lui
c'est ça qui frappe c'est qu'on commence
à voir des égards pour cet homme
il ya un autre témoignage qui est un
témoignage de formanoir le loewe de
samaa et qui parle également des
officiers qui étaient debout quand il
entrait dans la salle dans la chambre et
qui était découvert et qui ne s'asseyait
ne se couvraient que sur l'invite du
prisonnier
nous apprenons également qu'ont lieu
lumière et lui mettait son masque que
quand il sortait quand il rencontrait
des gens c'est quand il se promenait sur
la terrasse et oui voilà un certain
nombre de problèmes certain nombre de
témoignages un certain nombre d'étapes
nous voyons vivre cet homme là à sainte
marguerite
alors l'histoire de l'assiette
l'histoire de l'assiette elle a été bien
controversé c'est vous en souvenez
voltaire qui l'a raconté mais quand on
voit les grilles qui sont là dans la
jean monde on voit bien qu'il est
impossible de lancer une assiette à
travers ces trois grilles superposés et
contrarié alors une hypothèse a été
formulée pourquoi pape par les lieux les
lieux d'aisance qui étaient là en effet
qu'ils allaient directement dans la mer
c'est possible il est possible aussi que
cette assiette ce ne soit pas le
prisonnier masqué qu'il ait envoyé mais
que ce soit plutôt un pasteur protestant
il y avait également des pasteurs
protestants enfermé à l'île de sainte
marguerite
enfin là nous restons dans dans cette
ombre dans ce doute
nous savons qu'il y à un homme nous
savons maintenant nous sommes persuadés
qu'il s'agit de stages dauger cas les
autres sont morts et dubreuil ne compte
pas et pourquoi alors pourquoi ce masque
pourquoi ces précautions toujours et
samar va être nommé gouverneur de la
bastille on a dit que c'était le
maréchalat des geôliers de france et oui
il n'y a pas mieux comme prison il faut
dire que sa mare a franchi toutes les
étapes
il a fait une belle carrière à cause de
l'homme au masque parce qu'il est le
seul qui l'ait toujours suivi il est le
seul qu'il connaisse qui connaissent
tout de son aventure et peut-être même
maintenant son secret alors il va partir
avec l'homme est en route l'homme aura
toujours son masque de cannes à paris
cet homme voyagera masqué vous imaginez
la pression sur les routes de france et
aux étapes le soir à l'auberge quand ils
descendent temps d'une auberge
l'homme masqué nous avons encore un
témoignage très précis qui est toujours
le témoignage du neveu de saint-marc
formanoir il se trouve que ça marc était
devenue extrêmement riche parce que
gagner beaucoup d'argent dans ces
prisons en plus on lui donnait des
gratifications considérable c'est
toujours marcel pagnol qui a eu l'idée
de reprendre la sphère au point de vue
économique et il a fait des calculs très
remarquable sur ce qu'avait coûtés
l'homme au masque à l'état et il arrive
à des dizaines de nos millions
ce qui fait des milliards d'anciens
francs et oui ce valet qui parait-il les
terriens a coûté des milliards d'anciens
francs
pourquoi alors samar était devenu très
riche alors ils avaient acheté des
châteaux malheureusement les avait
jamais vus parce que c'est très bien
d'être geôliers on gagne de l'élan gagne
sa vie ses prestigieux dans un certain
sens enfin dans un sens par un certain
sens mais en fait il ne peut pas quitter
ces prisonniers alors de temps en temps
il avait droit de sortir une nuit rôle à
lamalou voix lui écrivait spécialement
vous aurez vous avez le droit d'aller
voir le gouverneur de nice mais rentré
le lendemain alors ses châteaux il les
avait mis les avait pas vus alors il
revient sur la route tel château de
paletot à villeneuve le roi et s'est
arrêté là nous avons des témoins les
paysans qui ont été interrogés par
formats noir et qui ont vu tout ça les
deux litière qui entre dans la cour du
château avec une litière c'était une
chaise porté par des chevaux des mulets
de lune décembre monsieur de saint marc
et de l'autre des 101 prisonniers masqué
aux cheveux blancs très grand de bonne
taille on nous dit avec simplement un
défaut physique qu'il avait le bas des
jambes et paix enfin belle allure bonne
taille et immédiatement s'amarrer le
prisonnier masques et s'engouffre dans
le château et le soir au dîner
saint-marc fera asseoir son prisonnier
le dos à la fenêtre de façon à ce que
les gens qui passent dans la cour et qui
on les devine on les devine ils sont là
ils tant il sait qu'ils sont là près de
la fenêtre ils veulent voir qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
alors personne ne verra rien parce que
le prisonnier a le dos tourné à la
fenêtre mais les gens qui viennent à la
fenêtre dans la cour voit comme ceux de
saint marc à de part et d'autre de son
assiette de pistolet c'est donc que les
précautions les a toujours on les tient
toujours et on repartira pour la
bastille on franchira la porte
saint-antoine et on arrivera dans la
plus célèbre prison de france où on
écrira l'homme au masque là aussi ça
fait un effet extraordinaire quand il
essence indiqué dans la cour l'homme au
masque hall c'est un beau visage noir
imaginez ils ont les crocs dans une
chambre qui s'appelle dans une cellule
qui s'appelle la troisième bertonnière
dans le jargon de la bastille c'est un
cube un cube qui à quatre mètres sur 4
mètres et sur 4 mètres c'est à dire
longueur largeur hauteur 4 mètres et va
y passer de 5 ans il a le droit d'aller
à la messe mais masquée le dimanche il a
le droit de voir un médecin mais le
médecin témoignera qu'il a vu sa langue
qui l'a vu sous son corps mais qu'il n'a
jamais vu son visage et il attend il
attend qwise la libération non il n'a
pas d'espoir il est résigné on le sait
par saint marc il ya longtemps qu'il dit
mon prisonniers mon ancien prisonnier
vie résigné dans même dans une lettre il
dit l'os dire qu'il vit content et en
1703 au mois de novembre sortir de la
messe un dimanche et la malaise il sera
reçu en confession et mourra le soir du
lendemain et on enterrera mme au
cimetière saint paul et on écrira sur
l'acte de décès comme nom de famille
mark yali marcali marché1 elle y
alors certains historiens ont été
préoccupés par ce marcali et pensant
encore à mattioli se sont dit mais au
fond est ce que par hasard ce serait
quand même pas ça la thèse mattioli a eu
des défenseurs il y en a plus mais il y
en a eu et le dernier a été fort bras
tanoh qui a défendu cette thèse avec
beaucoup de talent dix ans mais au fond
le seul seul homme important les autres
pourquoi dauger cet aval et lui ces deux
ministres du duc de mantoue
alors pourquoi est ce que ce ne serait
pas lui ont dit que qu'il est mort
sainte-marguerite mais si c'était d'auge
et qui était mort à sainte-marguerite
alors si il garde toutes ses chances
en fait ça ne tient pas ça ne tient pas
d'abord parce qu'il avait un valet qu'on
sait que le prisonnier mort à sainte
marguerite avait avalé c'est donc
mattioli et puis enfin il n'y avait pas
de raison garder le secret pour mattioli
l'europe entière connaissait son
aventure on l'avait publié les brochures
partout on savait qu'ils avaient été
enlevés alors à quoi bon
non il faut rejeter la thèse de mattioli
et on peut même dire que l'inscription
marc vialle y est une preuve de plus
qu'ils ne s'agit pas de mathieu lit
parce que la tradition n'était pas de
mettre le nom des prisonniers
et puis pourquoi avoir caché ce nom
toute une vie pour tout à coup le
dévoiler après sa mort ben non marque
alice
comme ça on l'a mis merkel pour m et le
problème maintenant se pose tout entier
parce que vous la connaissez la vie de
l'homme au masque depuis son
incarcération
vous l'avez vu d'abord gémir pendant
cinq ans seuls ensuite vous l'avez vu
cinq ans servir fouquet ensuite à cause
d'un mal en contre trou il a fallu faire
disparaître et on l'a jeté encore dans
une prison dans la tour d'en bas
d'ailleurs l'un de nos témoins de
sainte-marguerite dit on l'appelait
monsieur de la tour et oui parce que à
pignerol il était monsieur de la tour
d'en bas avec rivière y avait ces
messieurs de la tour d'en bas alors à
sainte-marguerite on se souvenait plus
que de la tour preuve de plus qu'il
s'agit bien toujours de la même filière
alors nous le retrouvons exil
toujours dans son atroce solitude et
puis à sainte marguerite où semble-t-il
son traitement est plus favorable
meilleur et puis enfin la bastille et
nous connaissant son nom il s'appelle
eustache dauger et nous savons que c'est
un valet et nous ne sommes pas plus
avancés
parce que pourquoi stage dauger at il
subi c'est 34 années de captivité
pourquoi lui at on infliger ces
précautions unique dans l'histoire des
prisons pourquoi surtout lui a t-on
infligé ce masque alors il faut dire que
aujourd'hui la plupart des historiens se
rallie à un stage noger en 1952 georges
mongrédien qui a publié un admirable
livre sur le masque de fer qui a fait
vraiment le point de la question avec
une netteté une objectivité à laquelle
il faut rendre hommage
georges mongrédien terminé en disant il
n'y a vraiment que deux possibilités
mattioli et dauger mais on sentait
parfaitement qu'il penchait vers nos
jeux et puis depuis il y a eu toute une
série d'historiens qui ont écrit en
partant de la certitude que c'était bien
dauger mais dauger pourquoi alors c'est
là qu'ils entrent en lice il est d'abord
maurice duvivier et maurice duvivier lui
estime que le stage d'auge il faut
l'identifier
un certain chevalier eustache dauger de
kawawii la remuer toutes les archives du
xviie siècle pour trouver à nos stages
jauger il a trouvé y en avait un il
s'appelait eustache dauger de cas voix
c'était même un compagnon de jeu de
louis xiv alors morue du vivier
en ce qu'il s'agit de lui d'autant plus
que c'était un des voiliers qu'ils
avaient trempé dans des affaires
extrêmement louche qu'il avait dû céder
justement parce qu'ils étaient des
voiliers son droit d'aînesse à son frère
cadet et maurice bouvier retrouvant un
homme mais les halles affaire des
poisons qui s'appelle dauger se dit
c'est le même c'est donc eustache dauger
de cas voix mêlées à l' affaire des
poisons et envoyer sans doute en prison
par louis xiv qui en souvenir de son
amitié d'enfance n'a pas voulu le
condamner à une peine infamante qui
aurait ce que tu es le scandale dans sa
famille malheureusement depuis on a
trouvé trace de stage d'oviedo sts de
stage dauger de cas voie après 16 169
sait tenir après la date d'incarcération
de l'omo masse
s'agirait pas du même ça ne gêne pas la
dernière historienne de la faire madame
marie madeleine mast qui elle dansait
dans un livre également très brillant tu
veux dire que tous ces livres sont très
brillants et on peut en lire un an lire
deux ans lire prend s'ennuie jamais
parce que à chaque fois c'est du nouveau
c'est une nouvelle thèse une nouvelle
hypothèse et marie-madeleine mast elle
reprend liposthey de stage dojo k voix
mais elle pense à autre chose
elle a été frappé par la ressemblance
qu'il y as entre louis dauger de cas
voix frères d'eustache et louis xiv et
d'ailleurs on voit ici sur un document à
gauche à gauche
un gros plan du bas du visage louis xiv
et à droite un gros plan du visage de
louis dauger de cas voix ya une certaine
ressemblance est vrai et madame mast se
demande si finalement le père des deux
jets de cailloux intime à la cour
n'aurait pas été l'amant d'anne
d'autriche
il aurait donc été le père de louis xiv
attribué faussement louis xiii en même
temps que le père de ses enfants
légitimes d'où la ressemblance et
c'était ça le secret d'état que portait
en lui le stage d'ojai de cas voix alors
si le stage dojo k voit comme le pense
madame mast a conspiré contre louis xiv
il ya là deux arguments liel un lourd
secret il y à là la ressemblance
d'où une explication possible
évidemment il y à 7 ce manuscrit et
cette lettre qui sont postérieurs à 769
madame masse tu essayes de sang
l'arrangé ça n'est pas mon avis
absolument déterminant mais disons que
son livre est également assez
convaincant quand il y a également
monsieur jean christian petitfils lui
aussi croit à dauger mais il pense que
ce dauger était vraiment avaler et que
tout simplement louvois lui avait
demandé d'empoisonner colbert
son vieux rival il est exact et un
moment colbert a été gravement malade on
a parlé d'une tentative d'empoisonnement
le cours est donc raté mais nous voient
se serait trouvé gêné par la présence de
dauger et l'aurait donc jeté en prison
d'où le lourd secret il fallait que nos
jeunes ne révèle jamais à personne là
encore une solution il ya aussi le livre
de monsieur pierre jacques arese très
très brillant lui aussi est là monsieur
arrive nous surprend parce que monsieur
arese tient pour dauger naturellement
comme tout le monde comme nous tous mais
pense que fouquet n'est pas mort en 680
qu'en fait il y avait autour du roi des
pressions pour libérer fouquet que le
roi se sentait quelque peu aculé et ne
voulait pas libéré fouquet alors que
faire et bien dire qu'il est mort et on
annonce sa mort et on le met dans la
tour d'en bas à la place de dauger
évidemment ça explique des choses ça
explique également la différence de
traitement parce qu'on remarque pendant
une partie de la captivité à pignerol
on traite mon dieu formal dauger à
sainte-marguerite on traite mieux si ça
n'est pas le même ça se comprend disons
que c'est très séduisant aussi mais que
comme finalement toutes ces thèses y
manque la pièce déterminante ce sont
finalement des supputations d'historiens
qui essaye de se dire voilà ce qui a pu
peut-être se produire mais la pièce
déterminante le document qui est
nécessaire à l'histoire ce document
manque toujours
et j'en arrive à marcel pagnol je vous
ai cité son nom plusieurs fois parce
qu'il se trouve que cet immense auteur
dramatique
cet homme qu'il forage il faut admirer
plus que n'importe qui cet homme que
j'admire profondément et vous aussi
c'est dans la dernière partie de sa vie
passionnée pour le masque de
il a travaillé de nombreuses années et
lui il revient et oui j'allais dire tout
simplement mais il revient à la thèse du
frère jumeau de louis xiv
cody marcel pagnol dit mais c'est dauger
mais naturellement ces deux messieurs
les historiens vous êtes tous d'accord
c'est dauger mais comme vous ne savez
rien de dauger laissez moi moi marcel
pagnol donner une veine autre identité à
dauger
on l'a baptisé dauger quand il est
arrivé mais c'était pas dauger c'était
le frère jumeau de louis xiv
évidemment l'acquis de marcel pagnol
c'est ce côté financier ce sont ces
sommes énormes il est le premier à
souligner ça pourquoi avoir dépensé tant
d'argent et puis finalement le masque
alors là aussi on est séduit par ce
livre de marcel pagnol
on est séduit tout en l'étant pas
absolument convaincu je me souviens d'en
avoir parlé avec lui et lui avoir dit
mais il ya une chose qui me gêne dans
votre thèse c'est que à un moment donné
on donne dauger comme vale à fouquet et
quand on connaît louis xiv cet orgueil
immense qu'il a du sens des bourbons de
son propre sang du sang royal lui sans
les rois est-ce que même son frère est
ensuite est en prison il aurait toléré
qu'on fasse de lui un valet c'est une
chose que j'ai j'arrive difficilement à
croix alors là aussi tu es séduisante
brillante vous pensez bien marcel pagnol
l'écrivant on lit son livre comme un
roman mais là aussi il manque le
document alors
alors je me demande quand même s'il faut
pas revenir au fameux trou bah oui vous
vous aimez le trou dans le mur parce
qu'il ya tout de même deux époques dans
l'histoire de l'homme au masque la
première où il ne faut rien entendre de
son secret bon c'est ça uniquement il a
un secret à se créer nord il faut pas
qu'on l'entende personnes l'entente mais
après le trou il faut qu'on pense qu'il
est libéré à cause de lauzun donc il
faut que plus jamais personne au monde
ne le vois que personne ne puisse aller
dire un jour à lauzun vous savez doré
que vous avez cru libéré au il est
toujours là il est à exil il était cette
marguerite il était la bastille alors ce
qu'il vous a raconté c'est vrai et c'est
georges mongrédien qui a fait remarquer
qu en 1798 quand saint-marc emmène
masquer son prisonnier de sainte
marguerite à la bastille lowe's est
toujours en vie alors finalement est-ce
qu'il ne s'agirait pas simplement de st
le masque la chaise couverte de toile
cirée n'aurait que ce but unique
empêcher que personne ne sache que
dauger vie et on en reviendrait pour le
problème uniquement aux secrets de
dauger et ça ce serait nous le
connaissons nous noie dans les centres
est-ce que nous le connaîtrons un jour
qui sait
il ya toujours de l'espoir mon histoire
on peut toujours penser qu'une source
inédite apparaître un jour peut-être
connaître en nous un jour le secret de
stage dauger pourrons-nous à ce
moment-là dire eh bien maintenant on
sait pourquoi est ce que ce sera mieux
si on le sait le savoir c'est peut être
ce qu'il est ce qu'il est permis de se
demander parce qu'au fond une énigme non
résolues comme celle que nous venons de
vivre ensemble pendant une heure mais
une énigme non résolus ce ça fait rêver
et c'est bon de rêver vous trouvez pas
tandis qu'une énigme résolue mais je
crois que ça ressemble un peu aux jouets
tant convoitée par un enfant pendant des
jours cet enfant a dit je veux te veut
se jouer je le veux et puis on lui donne
puis à ce moment-là il regarde pendant
cinq minutes ils jouent avec pendant
cinq minutes et c'est fini alors moi je
me demande si tout de même ça ne vaut
pas mieux que nous ne sachions pas
pourquoi le stage dauger est devenu le
masque de fer
[Musique]